I was dealing with the London Ambulance
Service really just as a sort of case
but as it turns out this seems to be
true nationwide as well and the crisis
in the London Ambulance Service can't
really be exaggerated I mean they
predict there going to be 600 paramedics
down by the end of the year that's a
third of all the paramedics they've got
so because they were they're resigning
their quit seems like they're quitting
and so I was asking as you say why and
I'm in the first piece Isles to question
and for the following two weeks I was
inundated with emails and calls and I
went to meet several paramedics who
talked to me you know under conditions
of sort of secrecy and they said I've
got here some of the things they said
the real problem isn't pay it isn't
really over work it's bullying in within
their management system
they say for instance there's a
possessive pervasive sense that
management try to get you people
paramedics are afraid to speak out
because of the repercussions they say
it's all about conditions at work
bullying management lack of equipment
one here says I left the London
Ambulance Service four months ago and my
boss my new boss says I behave like
someone who's been in an abusive
relationship there's even talk of the
service having a suicide watch list
because paramedics are so unhappy now on
suicide watch yeah I don't know if
that's true but it's least interesting
because that's what paramedics are
saying that management are aware of how
unhappy these paramedics are and so they
have a watch list for people who might
be committing suicide and they're
leaving in droves whether they're
suicidal or not they're certainly
leaving and that leaves all of us I
enjoy so Julia and the government's had
pledged to keep the health spending
budget protected this was supposed to be
the theme of the four years here they
might cut and police that they might cut
even education but the health service
would stay intact something appears to
be going wrong doesn't this here
you're right Fraser and just to pick up
on what Mary was just saying
unfortunately what we're hearing in this
story are the familiar themes of
bullying
in the culture in the NHS being one
where people are leaving rather than
actually saying no this is going wrong
and whistleblowing
because they're worried about their
their jobs are worried about
repercussions they want to get other
jobs elsewhere elsewhere in the NHS
that's right absolutely you won't work
elsewhere if you do that so positions
driven but by cuts or anything we're
just simple mismanagement well I think
there are there are three areas that we
can look at in terms of the source of
the problem and again three areas for
the solution as well so starting with
they they're professionals themselves I
think that we know that hospitals know
where the poor performing GPS are where
people will call an ambulance or turn up
at A&E because they can't access their
GP I think the hospital knows that you
can bet your bottom dollar that the
ambulance service no such as well so
there's an issue around access to
medical care and that is isn't being
people aren't being in particular
general practice I'm not being held
accountable for that so that's one
problem and that's a respective of
funding but then there is also an issue
and that you pick this up in your
article marry around the board
discussion that happened around what was
going on in the London Ambulance Service
I thought that was really tell
extraordinary I mean we all know that
you know everyone complains about their
work and these people and paramedics are
unhappy so you assume and you know the
management knows you so you're gonna
take it seriously I mean as we discussed
this is a third of the whole service sub
leaving by the end of the year a huge
sort for and you've been going through
the board minute and they say this was
active says things like on oh how we're
going to recruit more deaf paramedics
into the service house item 1 on the
agenda and someone one of the Mets the
non-executive director says on and very
concerned about the air quality in
London for the parameters now that's the
least of their worries there's suicidal
with stress I mean it's
yes sir quality and well-being nowhere
to be seen and in theory politicians are
saying that's what boards should be
discussing yeah and practice it's
nowhere on any agenda fixes well that
comes to this second group of people and
these comes back to your point phrase
about politicians are also funding I
think politicians have despite Angeles
attempts to remove politicians from the
NHS and that hasn't happened and sadly
it's never going to happen and
management chief execs constantly
looking over their shoulders to see
whether they're being checked whether
they're meeting targets whether they are
doing things as they should do I mean
one sad but accurate fact is that the
average lifespan of a chief executive in
an NHS Foundation Trust is 18 months
that's that's how long they last before
they quit and move on absolutely and and
so there's a there's a culture of fear
which comes top-down from the
politicians focusing on targets focusing
on waiting times that that is that is
what happens on the ground even though
the rhetoric is about quality and
well-being and safety of patients it
should be asking you know a lot of time
whether the targets are the right
targets I mean it could responding to
you know a chest pain in eight minutes
but how many of those people reporting
chest pains did actually go on to have a
heart attack
were they heart attack patients actually
not very many of them were so yeah I was
really evaluating these targets have one
so frightened about not hitting Julia
it's difficult to though I mean if
you've got the system where the
government has got exclusive control as
it doesn't mean NHS if you don't have
targets it's hard to get quality
assurance otherwise isn't it mean our
target is just inevitable if you're
going to have the NHS run as one massive
bureaucracy
I think the some targets are and that
comes back to the point that Mary just
made some targets are important but
others such as ludicrous so why is there
a one fixed target for everyone in a any
of for hours now if you turn up and have
your emergency trauma patients
now you should be seen immediately no
matter where you are on the queue if
you're someone who has come along for a
bandage to be reput on your leg well
really you should be left to lose it to
sit there for as long as it takes for
you to go off and find someone else to
do it because it's romantic use of the
services there is a triage system isn't
that when you're going to a uni you see
somebody pretty quickly and don't the
more or less assess whether you can
weight it with you can't well your
registered but that's to make sure that
you don't breach to four-hour waiting
targets so you know the actual reason
for registering you is not to ensure
that the most needy are seen first is to
make sure that no one breaches that
targets so some targets are are
essential and it's part of good
management to have you know key
performance indicators but there are far
too many targets which actually lead to
to the culture that we currently have
which is one of fear and bullying
because we're not going to meet this
target we're going to get criticized so
and so might lose their job and the
focus again it's not on quality and
safety you know it's on those targets so
we needed an intelligent approach to
targets and I just wanted to answer your
question about funding the NHS from an
NHS budget has been ring-fenced and that
is that that's as it is but what
politicians have refused to engage in
it's a discussion about what that money
is spent on and they've gone on
pretending that we can carry on funding
everything that we're currently doing
that the the creep that we've seen the
NHS and the services that provided over
the past sixty five years is something
that we don't actually have to have a
public conversation about because there
are is a limited capacity there are
pressures both cost pressures through
new technologies which are fantastic but
to say that we can give the best
everyone is completely disingenuous it's
it's a false that falsehood so
politicians need to step up to the plate
and have no be bored enough to have a
conversation with the public about what
do we want the NHS to be therefore what
are the priorities whether we should
fund sex change operations and things
like that could be one of the
conversations to be had yes and know
what what we what do we want it to be in
the 21st century we all wanted to stay
we want it to remain free at the point
of use but what you know what should not
actually be included in that
service because we can't do everything
so what would doesn't really need to be
letting some guts and it takes actually
caring about patients not about sort of
spin and presentation yes I know it
really needs you know some grown-up
cross-party discussions to happen if
politicians are serious about wanting to
protect the NHS wanting it to be there
for the future wanting to be there for
their children and grandchildren then
they owe us to have this grown-up
discussion and funding is that of course
or one aspect but you that good
management cost the same as bad
management and a lot of what you
described here is just simply being
people behaving badly and you say there
is a former chief executive of London
ambulances Peter Bradley who actually
got it right yeah I mean it could be the
case that he was dealing with fewer
Coons even in 2012 there were fewer
calls to my mind nine however you know
as I understand it he gave an hour and
off this time every year to each
ambulance station and because they felt
listened to they were more paid to do
their work all and it's again because
they're terrific
you know heartfelt vocational people and
as I understand it they're top brass now
don't do that same sort of listening and
caring and I'm sure that would go a long
way to alleviate the stress that the
frontline stop feeling in this case but
you always hear stories in the NHS of
the chief execs who do that kind of
thing you know they stand out those who
spend time you know on the wards in the
corridors talking to staff you know
they're the ones who pick up on what the
real issues are who can meet those needs
and engender goodwill amongst to start
if you see that's in every organisation
that's true in our organization it's
true in schools you know however tough
the kids a good head teacher will have
the will have sort of the support of his
staff and morale he'll be transformed by
him now we know that em journey behind
the health secretary is a fan of the
podcast and listens to it so we've got a
chance here Julia to send him a message
what do you think he needs to do to make
sure
scandals like the one mary has revealed
in this week's magazine happen less
frequently or what commuters headed off
before because I can imagine this will
get worse between now and the election
it could do I think a key message is to
think about the complexity of the
current system we have we've got 999
we've got urgent care centres we've got
one-on-one we've got out of
got minor injuries who have got accident
emergency three levels of accident
emergency sensors the public don't know
where to go they're completely confused
so we need a coherent consistent message
about when it's appropriate to use
services and that's something that he
can do and I think they also need to
request the public that they use
services differently because again Mary
you picked up in in your work that I
think it was in your first blog piece
they abuse up nine nine nine burn
someone yeah both those services you
know it's free at the point of use
people just use it like calling a cab
and we know that a lot of people abuse
alcohol and then they use services
inappropriately and the government's
thinking of charging them now when they
turn up drunk into A&E isn't it the
thing is you can't really say to people
can you please stop using 999 as much
because they are going to anyway you
know in a call center you can have a
system that effectively just just you
know discriminates between urgent care
and no no drink at the moment there's a
sort of risk-averse tendency well send
an ambulance in case they do tonight
appeal maybe we have to manage our
expectations sometimes you know and I
think we can learn from some of the
other services West Midlands Fire
Service for instance a few years ago in
fact that the laws been there for some
time you can charge you can find people
for inappropriate use of services in spa
service a couple of years ago raised
thirty thousand pounds for charging
people for calling them out because so
cat was up a tree or because they were
locked out but and it no things that may
be needed dealing with but what
inappropriate use of a service no we're
used to paying speeding fines were used
to stomping up on we've abused the
system we should apply that the city NHS
as well I do hope your hands listening